three weeks after
election day the u.s government is
finally recognizing
joe biden as president-elect and
beginning the formal transition process
although president trump says he's still
not conceding
in the past this handoff from an
outgoing president to the next
office holder has typically been carried
out with grace
even after bruising campaigns and when
the new president has very different
goals
chip reid has been looking into the
history of this essential
custom please know that you will have my
my support in unifying and leading the
nation
in a normal presidential election the
losing candidate first
offers words of support whatever our
differences
we are fellow americans then comes a
meeting of former rivals we
should work together a symbol it's time
for the country
to come together because if you succeed
then the country succeeds
then the real work gets underway
he can start naming officials he can
start articulating policies
he started to talk to foreign leaders
the custom is as old as the presidency
itself
according to david marchick director of
the center for presidential transition
for 223 years we've had a peaceful
transition of power ever since george
washington handed the keys to john adams
we've had good transitions we've had bad
transitions this is an unusual
transition bad
transitions have happened before after
the election of 1860
seven states seceded from the union
before president-elect abraham lincoln's
inauguration
and in 2000 a lengthy recount delayed
the transition
by more than a month i offer my
concession leaving president-elect
george w
bush just 37 days before his
inauguration
about half the normal amount of time
george walker bush do solemnly swear
the bipartisan 911 commission concluded
that the shortened transition left the
country
vulnerable to a terrorist attack because
national security officials
were playing catch-up most americans
think this transition is just beginning
that's not true
the transition works started the day
after the last uh inauguration there are
hundreds of career officials all across
the government that prepare
from whomever wins in a typical
transition teams from both sides are in
place
months before a winner is decided and
the sitting president works to help his
successor succeed martha joint kumar has
been studying
transitions for decades transition is
supposed to be one where the
outgoing administration is helpful to
the incoming administration
in terms of making available materials
from the departments and agencies
in modern times has there ever been a
president who has resisted
participating in the transition no they
have not
you've had the the presidential
transitions act
which made it very clear that the
federal government had a role in
transitions
and with the coronavirus still raging
the stakes for a smooth transfer of
power
are extremely high there are thousands
of officials
all across the government particularly
the pentagon and the department of
health
that want to get the vaccine out to 300
million americans and the sooner the
biden team can start working with those
officials
the more ready they're going to be on
january 20th
the general services administration is
usually an obscure
government agency but with the
president's permission it has now given
the biden transition team
access to six million dollars in
transition funds
and that means they don't have to do
their own fundraising to pay their
expenses
anymore tony that's something they're
calling him the apparent winner i keep
thinking of that historian who said
we've had good transitions and bad
transitions and this one
is unusual very diplomatic i wonder what
they'll be saying in 30 years hence
all right you'll see i'll stick around
for it chip thank you very much we
appreciate it ahead